c'est noël aux mille lumières qu'a
choisi le château de langeais pour sa
décoration de fête des bougies qui
scintille entre ses murs du moyen âge
donnant un air magique aux meubles et
tapisseries d'époque sans risque d'
incendies
[Musique]
la magie de noël s'arrêtera en fait ce
sont des bougies tout simplement à piles
les bougies électriques non les verts
rien au charme des intérieurs et
permettent de recréer une ambiance
proche de l'époque les bougies des
cierges était et est recherché c'est un
produit de luxe au moyen âge
donc les seigneurs essayer de s'en
procurer en avoir et puis bien
évidemment plus il en avait plus ça leur
permettait monter leurs richesses
donc il en installer beaucoup surtout à
cette période de l'année alors on va
allumer les bougies installés dans les
salles du château il ya un petit peu
partout ça qu'un mythe créé une belle
ambiance pour les fêtes de noël
décorations noël éclairage à la bougie
investissent toutes les pièces de
l'imposante bâtisse
il ya effectivement des grandes salles
d'apparat comme la salle du banquet où
là on a ce côté festif où cette table
est complètement décoré et puis dans les
autres salles qui sont d'essentiellement
des chambres là on a on a un petit côté
très intime
quinon qui plaît beaucoup s'il ya
vraiment une atmosphère qui s'en dégage
l'éclairage ici au château et est peu
important en plus donc ça met vraiment
en valeur toutes ses bougies dans ses
salles cet investissement dans
l'opération noël au pays des châteaux
sur le thème de la lumière vise à offrir
une destination touristique hivernale et
le succès est au rendez vous la
fréquentation au château a effectivement
augmenté depuis le début du mois dès
qu'on a lancé l'opération avec une
fréquentation plus importante notamment
les week-ends donc les tourangeaux 1 les
locaux venaient beaucoup voir le château
décorée pour l'occasion et faisait
d'ailleurs là la tournée si je puis dire
des cinq châteaux qui participent à
cette opération
et puis là depuis le début des vacances
on voit également une augmentation de
cette fréquentation avec les décorations
qui attire le public et puis aussi les
animations qui attire la le jeune public
les enfants pour les enfants
beat princesse et armure de chevalier
ont toujours autant de succès et on
comprend mieux l'absence de celle-ci au
moyen-âge
[Musique]